madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi 14
décembre
un vrai coup de froid sur la france les
températures seront à nouveau en baisse
cette nuit le plan d'urgence hivernale
sera renforcé les associations
mobilisées
un an après le coup de colère des
enfants de don quichotte nous tenterons
de voir si les promesses ont été tenues
pour les mal logés
il y aura un nouveau procès colonna les
avocats du berger corse condamné hier
soir la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre du préfet
erignac ont fait appel de cette décision
la tension est perceptible au sein des
nationalistes plusieurs explosions ont
eu lieu sur l'île ces dernières 24
heures l'urgence pour la planète à bali
personne ne souhaite porter la
responsabilité de l'échec des
négociations sur le réchauffement
climatique
les discussions sont toujours en cours
et cela alors que l'on a appris que la
fonte des glaces arctiques avait été
multiplié par trente durant le seul été
2007 où on et l'amérique sur la peine de
mort le pays semble de plus en plus
divisé la majorité des états restent
favorables pause exécution mais hier
pour la première fois depuis des années
le new jersey a décidé d'abolir la peine
capitale
reportage dans un instant enfin noël si
la mi temps de l'année scolaire l'heure
des bilans pour les élèves et pour les
parents des parents qui n'hésitent pas
parfois à mettre une pression trop forte
sur les enfants une obligation réussite
vous le verrez ce soir souvent mal vécue
les psychologues s'en inquiètent parole
d'enfant c'est le grand format de cette
édition
merci d'être avec nous ce vendredi soir
et commençons le journal par les
températures de ce week-end qui vont
chuter une nouvelle fois une vague de
froid assez clair regarder les
températures prévues pour cette nuit
-3 à rennes - 4 à reims - 6 à aurillac
le froid et ses conséquences pour les
plus démunis
il y un nom souvenez-vous l'association
des enfants de don quichotte faisait la
une de l'actualité en multipliant les
opérations pour les sans abri elle
estime que les promesses de l'époque
n'ont pas été tenues voyons ce soir
concrètement où en sont les conditions
d'hébergement avec le reportage de yann
gicquel et burning
are you depuis le 1er octobre chaque
soir l'association la mie de pain
affiche complet 600 repas servis les 450
lits occupés
nous sommes ici dans le plus grand
centre de sans abri d'europe en plein
coeur de paris
entre ces deux images tout juste cent
vingt ans quasiment jour pour jour les
petits gosses que l'association avait
sorti de la rue ont décidé qu'il n'y
avait aucune raison de donner des
miettes aux oiseaux transit et d'ignorer
les hommes qui avaient faim depuis la
précarité s'est aggravée au point que le
gouvernement a mis en place cette année
un plan d'action de grande ampleur mais
malgré les meilleures volontés du monde
ce plan se heurte à la réalité complexe
c'est un problème de société majeur
c'est ça qu'on essaye de dire de plus en
plus on peut toujours bricolé améliorée
est d'ailleurs souvent ça améliore le
quotidien des gens les dispositifs
mais si vous voulez la plus grande la
plus grande tristesse que l'on pourrait
avoir ce serait de considérer qu'il faut
simplement mettre les personnes à l'abri
pour que nous ne les voyons plus dans la
rue six cent mille neuf cent mille sans
abri difficilement quantifiable cette
population isolée cabossés de la vie
comme disait l'abbé pierre
s'excuseraient presque d'être là qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait pour vous aider
dans rien
rien
je suis bien comme ça pour l'instant ma
vie
je peux pas faire autrement alors
parce que j'avais ce qu'il fallait avant
la maison lever tôt et marié un enfant
devant l'enfant
non
dès lors très vendeuse si le froid des
jours derniers et les fêtes de fin
d'année et rendre la situation encore
plus intolérable c'est toute l'année et
plus particulièrement au printemps que
les sans abri meurent le plus dans la
rue et autres images du jour après 11
semaines le campement rue de la banque à
paris sera levé dans la soirée un accord
a enfin été trouvé pour reloger les
familles en situation précaire le
ministère du logement a annoncé que les
quelques 400 dossier serait traité au
plus vite certains dans les prochains
jours mais le ministère a tenu à
prévenir que ce type d'accord ne se
reproduirait pas il y aura donc un autre
procès colonna
je vous le disais en titre ses avocats
mais également le parquet ont décidé de
faire appel de décisions qui hier soir
l'a condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité mais sans peine de sûreté
un verdict largement commenté et
critiqué par les nationalistes en corse
les dernières 24 heures ont été marquées
par plusieurs explosions et notamment
celle de la villa de l'une des amies de
la veuve du préfet erignac sur place
nathalie jourdan raymond chape l'art
cargèse berceau divan colonna l'enfant
du pays a demandé à ses proches de ne
pas pleurer mais pour beaucoup au
village c'est la tristesse qui prime
il verse vous avez réagi comment la
mesure du jeu il a une grosse larme
on a beaucoup de peine pour pierre est
sa compagne
toute sa famille son fils seront
attentifs vraiment erreur judiciaire
procès politique
ils sont nombreux ici à penser que le
doute n'a pas profité à l'accusé colonna
ya pas de justice dans ce pays
puisqu'on a aucune preuve et puis enfin
d'après ce qu'on dit un tireur est hélas
il y en a trois donc c'est tout simple
c'est un peu bizarre
hier soir deux heures à peine après le
verdict cinq villes a été visée par des
attentats dans la région de bonifacio
quatre ont subi des dégâts la plus
touchée est celle d'une amie d'enfance
de la veuve de claude erignac
un peu plus tard la façade de la
gendarmerie de zicavo est mitraillée
chant rassemblement la condamnation du
berger fait sortir de jeunes corses dans
la rue à ajaccio ils ont protesté dans
le calme devant la préfecture
les raisons c'est tout d'abord notre
habitat français que la jeunesse corse
est conscient et a une conscience
politique que la jeunesse corse ne se
laissera pas faire
conte et constructive en colonne
mobilisation également à corte où les
collégiens ont barricadé l'entrée de
leur établissement
leurs aînés de la faculté ont fait de
même le retour sur l'île de la famille
d'yvan colonna est prévue ce soir vers
23 heures
ensuite ce sera à nouveau la tante avant
le prochain combat celui du procès en
appel
alors après cinq semaines de débats
voyons ce soir comment les sept juges de
la cour d'assises spéciale en sont
arrivés à ce verdict retour sur un
procès pas comme les autres avec
dominique verdeilhan et jean-marc donc
colonna coupable un verdict que ses
proches n'imaginais pas il n'aime pas
l'accord jusqu'à tuer un homme avait
plaidé l'un de ses avocats
pendant un mois yvan colonna n'a cessé
de répéter que le patriote corse qu'il
était était innocent le 15 novembre un
médecin légiste jette le trou pour lui
le tireur mesure au moins un mètre 83
yvan colonna mesure 1 m 72 reconvoqué à
la barre l'expert est moins formel
une semaine plus tard défilé à la barre
des témoins de la scène du crime
certains ont vu deux hommes d'autres
insolent un unis paiement à 8,3 tous
sont unanimes ils ne reconnaissent pas
yvan colonna en garde à vue certaines
époux certains membres du commando ont
cité abondamment yvan colonna avant de
se rétracter
trop tard la mise en cause ne sera
d'être à ce d'autant plus qu'à la barre
les mêmes le disculpe du bout des lèvres
je sais que tu es un homme d'honneur si
tu avais participé à cette action tu
l'aurais revendiquer lance laconiquement
alain ferrandi
on a senti chez membres de ce commando
qui avait déjà été condamné
définitivement qu'il y avait
incontestablement quelque chose qui
n'était pas de l'ordre du soutien mais
plutôt du rejet à quel moment vous pensé
au cours de ces cinq semaines
d'audiences que là bas la balance un
tranchant
je pense que c'était évidemment au
moment où ceux qui sont accusés
sont venus
ledit sculpté de façon plus ou moins
habiles dernière carte de la défense le
transport de justice il devait être la
preuve de l'innocence de colonna
les sept magistrats en ont jugé
autrement il y avait bien trois hommes
pour assassiner claude erignac
l'espace d'un dimanche yvan colonna est
revenu en corse
sa corse le verdict d'hier a fait
s'éloigner un retour définitif au tchad
le procès des membres de l'association
l'arche de zoé commencera dans une
semaine exactement dans le box des
accusés il y aura je vous le rappelle si
français parmi eux un médecin qui
travaille dans le village de castellane
dans les alpes maritimes là bas depuis
le début des 50 jours de sa détention
on se mobilise autour de son épouse ce
matin à la population avait d'ailleurs
décidé d'organiser une manifestation
vincent capus olivier prod'homme étaient
sur place à bout de nerfs
antonia craque le conseil général des
alpes-de-haute-provence vient de voter à
l'unanimité une motion demandant à
nicolas sarkozy le rapatriement de son
mari le docteur philippe van winkelberg
détenus au tchad depuis cinquante jours
qu'on écoute enfin philippe qu'on sache
qu'il est innocent cole innocente qui
rentrent vite vite vite vite là rien à
faire dans les prisons tchadienne rien
et encore moins dans son court clip
ce matin les habitants de castellane
sont venus jusqu'à digne soutenir le
médecin du village
derrière les banderoles ses amis mais
aussi sa famille je suis très très
inquiet tout oui parce que là bas ils
ont été condamnés avant de avant d'être
jugé bon les a pas entendus en fait
castellane attend le retour de son
docteur et affiche sa solidarité aux
fenêtres
une fois par semaine entonnait apporte
au comité de soutien les dernières
nouvelles de son mari
dans ces lettres du tchad le médecin de
l'arche de zoé crient à l'injustice
je garde espoir car je sais que c'est
impossible de nous laisser la plus les
gens connaîtront la vérité plus ils
trouveront la situation injuste et plus
ils protesteront contre notre mise en
accusation n'a pas participé au montage
de l'opération ni au tri des enfants ni
au choix des enfants ne l'a même pas vu
les mais les chefs de tribus à fait que
celui qui suit le dr van winkelberg sera
jugé dans une semaine devant la cour
criminelle de n'djamena pour enlèvement
d'enfants il encourt de 5 à 20 ans de
travaux forcés le procès débutera le 21
décembre au lendemain de l'anniversaire
de mariage de philippe et antonia et
dans ce dossier sachez que ce soir à
l'elysée nicolas sarkozy reçoit les
familles des membres de l'association
une réunion afin je cite de faire le
point après sa rencontre à paris avec le
président tchadien idriss deby les
vingt-sept étaient réunis aujourd'hui à
bruxelles au coeur des discussions
l'union européenne l'épineuse question
du kosovo source de division président
nicolas sarkozy a d'ailleurs souhaité
affirmer que la serbie avait un avenir
dans l'union à condition de respecter
les droits de l'homme mais également
l'indépendance du kosovo chef de l'état
qui est également revenu sur la
signature du traité simplifié à lisbonne
un traité qui ne sera pas soumis à
référendum en france on écoute j'ai la
france d'organiser un référendum
à la minute où la france le fait la
grande bretagne le fait est qu'elle ait
la chance que la grande bretagne est un
oui et à ce moment là à quoi ça sert
aurait servi de faire le traité
simplifié qui doit être ratifié à
l'unanimité pour entrer en vigueur
je le dis comme je le pense je suis
profondément européen
on a besoin de l'europe on a d'ailleurs
besoin de la grande bretagne en europe
et c'est pas maintenant qu'on l'a remis
l'europe sur les rails qu'il faut aller
s'amuser à l'ére cas c'est ce que par
ailleurs on a eu tant de mal à
raccommoder nicolas sarkozy qui a
également annoncé qu'il entendait invité
le pape benoît 16 à venir en france il
officialisera cette invitation lors de
sa visite au vatican jeudi prochain
longue très longue et même trop longue
pour 52% des personnes interrogées par
nos confrères du journal le parisien
la visite du colonel kadhafi n'est pas
une bonne chose le président libyen qui
me quittera la france que demain ainsi
après
le lourd hier sa limousine blanche est
arrivé ce matin à versailles
nouvelle étape d'une visite diplomatique
et finalement également très touristique
jérôme berlin hervé poggio au cinquième
jour le kadhafi tour et rodez
l'interminable convoi se met en branle
comme d'habitude des heures de retard
sur un programme un certain aujourd'hui
le guide libyen a choisi versailles
ici sont célébrés deux de ses héros
napoléon et surtout louis xiv un colonel
au look soigné pour l'occasion blouson
d'aviateur bottes et surtout chapka sur
la tête jean jacques aillagon président
du domaine lui fait la visite
la galerie des glaces puis le trône doré
du roi soleil le guide s'arrête
longuement et prend la pose devant le
trône ouais que versailles a été conçu
par louis xiv comme une machine à
mettront en scène son propre pouvoir
sa propre puissance aujourd'hui je pense
que les chefs d'états les souverains qui
viennent à versailles n'y viennent pas
pour jouer à quatorze le château n'est
officiellement pas fermée au public mais
un important dispositif policier est
déployé ce qui rend la visite des
touristes un peu pénible
on sent d'ailleurs à visiter cet
événement nous sommes une vraie ville de
digne parc
avant de partir le guide inscrit
quelques mots sur le livre d'or
le magnifique château de versailles est
un modèle d'originalité de création et
d'art humain
quand on rentre dans ce château on ne
peut qu être ébloui par tant de beauté
il replonge dans sa limousine nouvelle
destination mystère c'est rambouillet un
autre château pour une partie de chasse
au gros gibier sanglier chevreuil nul ne
le sait mouammar kadhafi doit quitter la
france demain à 11 heures
direction l'espagne à l'étranger aux
états unis depuis le début de l'année 42
personnes ont été exécutées
la peine de mort reste applicable dans
37 états américains ils sont toujours
majoritaires mais les opposants à la
peine capitale ne cesse de marquer des
points
dernier exemple en date la décision
prise hier par l'état du new jersey
d'abolir la peine de mort sur place
alain de chalvron 40 dimon il va falloir
faire des travaux à la prison de trenton
dans le new-jersey démanteler le couloir
de la mort où végètent 11 détenus parmi
lesquels robert marshall pensionnaires
des lieux depuis 18 ans pour le meurtre
de sa femme il était temps de se
débarrasser de cette chose là c'est dur
de vivre avec cette épée de damoclès
vous pensez toujours que votre dernier
au cours sera épuisée que vous partirez
pour votre dernière promenade
la dernière personne exécutée dans cet
état là étaient sur cette chaise
électrique en 1963 le new-jersey
observer un moratoire de fait
mais il fallait du courage à ses
parlementaires locaux pour passer au
stade supérieur
l'abolition officielle il est très
difficile pour un législateur de voter
contre la peine de mort
il peut être critiqué pour être noués ou
devant le criminel et de manquer de
compassion pour les victimes
mais ce vote de new-jersey montre qu'on
peut tout de même le faire en plusieurs
étapes pourraient être encouragé par
l'exemple du new jersey car en dépit des
apparences la peine de mort est en perte
de vitesse aux etats-unis le nombre
d'exécutions a chuté de moitié
certains états importants comme
l'illinois ont cessé toute exécution
devant le nombre de condamnés innocentés
par des tests adn
il faut absolument faire tout ce qui est
possible pour éviter qu'un innocent
faussement condamnés puissent être
exécutées d'autres états comme new york
ont déclaré la peine de mort
anticonstitutionnelle
la cour suprême fédérale elle même va
l'an prochain statuer sur la légalité du
mode d'exécution par injection létale
le principal problème reste l'opinion
publique bon an mal an et en dépit des
débats deux tiers des américains reste
en faveur de la peine de mort des images
en provenance du liban maintenant à
beyrouth avec les obsèques du général
françois el hajj assassinés cette
semaine dans un attentat à la voiture
piégée une journée de deuil national
avait été décrétée des milliers
personnes étaient présentes dans le
quartier chrétien la capitale le pays
est toujours dans l'impasse politique il
n'a pas su se donner un nouveau
président depuis la fin du mandat des
1000 lahoud
une tempête tropicale s'est abattue dans
les caraïbes et notamment sur la
république dominicaine le bilan est
lourd au moins 25 morts
le coeur de l'île a été touché notamment
les fabriques de rome et de tabac sont
les régions les plus pauvres du pays qui
ont été touchés l'explication karine
comazzi une vague de plus de vingt
mètres de haut déferle du barrage de
tavera ce quelques kilomètres en aval le
long de la rivière yake les habitants se
pressent sur les toits pour être secouru
loin des zones touristiques dans ces
petites communes agricole au coeur de la
république dominicaine
au moins 25 personnes sont mortes les
modestes maisons en bois typique de
cette partie très traditionnelle de
l'île n'ont pas résisté à la crue de la
rivière près de trente mille personnes
sont sans abri et déjà la polémique
pointe pour éviter que le barrage
n'auront le gouvernement fait déverser
les eaux de la rivière mais les
habitants n'ont pas été prévenus à temps
interviewé par la tv locale le président
élu de la question
nous avons demandé aux autorités une
évaluation immédiat des dégâts pour
déterminer comment le gouvernement va
pouvoir y remédier cette tempête
inhabituel en décembre et la deuxième
que les dominicains subissent en
quelques mois
et l'avenir de la planète se joue en ce
moment à bali l'enjeu est de taille et
les négociations sont toujours en cours
en vue d'un accord sur le réchauffement
climatique les états unis refusant
l'idée de fixer un objectif chiffré des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre des
hésitations des réticences et pourtant
le réchauffement climatique a des
conséquences de plus en plus visible
exemple dans les glaces de l'arctique
voici les nouveaux chiffres des
scientifiques américains ils sont
alarmants pour le seul été 2007 la
diminution de la banquise représente
près de 2 millions de kilomètres carrés
soit trois fois la france florence mavic
guillaume michel
un glaçon dans un verre d'eau chaude
l'image est à peine exagéré lorsque l'on
regarde cette animation satellite qui
zoome sur le pôle nord au cours de l'été
la banquise s'est rétractée à vitesse
grand v
pour vous donner une échelle de grandeur
c'est l'équivalent de trois fois la
france qui a fondu dans l'océan arctique
jusqu'en 2006 le taux moyen de perte de
glace l'été était de 63 mille kilomètres
carrés
cette année on atteint le chiffre
incroyable de 1 million 700 mille
kilomètres carrés
un constat particulièrement alarmant
pour les scientifiques
pour la première fois dans toute
l'histoire un passage maritime au nord
ouest du canada s'est ouvert ce n'est
pas inhabituel c'est tout simplement
exceptionnel exceptionnel
si les bateaux circulent désormais dans
des contrées autrefois prisonnière des
glaces c'est parce que l'océan arctique
s'est considérablement réchauffée plus 5
degrés celsius en s'amenuisant la
banquise ne renvoie plus les rayons du
soleil et la mer se transforme peu à peu
en bouilloires ce qui accélère donc la
fonte des glaces un cercle vicieux dont
l'activité humaine est responsable car
ce sont les gaz à effet de serre qui
entraîne ce bouleversement majeur dans
la vie de notre planète justice à
nouveau vous souvenez peut-être de cette
affaire qui avait fait la une de
l'actualité durant l'été 2006 lorsque le
cadavre d'un homme a été retrouvé au
large du portugal dans un trimaran avec
à son bord de français les français
interpellés
accusé du meurtre du propriétaire du
bateau est aujourd'hui condamné par la
justice portugaise à 24 ans de prison
hakim abdel khaleq jusqu'au bout ils
auront clamé leur innocence
intervenant à plusieurs reprises avant
la lecture du verdict
expulsé de la salle d'audience thierry
bay et sa demi-soeur corps une caspar
n'entendront même pas leur condamnation
24 ans de prison pour meurtre avec
préméditation et tentative de
dissimulation de cadavre en août 2006 au
portugal les deux français en barque sur
le trimaran d'andré le floch un skipper
passionné par la mer une violente
tempête fait chavirer le bateau
le couple est alors hélitreuillée depuis
un canot de sauvetage
mais à bord de l'intermezzo les
enquêteurs découvrent le corps d'andré
le floch les pieds les poings liés et
des lésions à la tête
les deux français affirme alors qu'ils
ont frappé et attaché le skipper parce
qu'il aurait tenté de violer corinne
caspar et c'est la tempête qui aurait
alors provoqué sa mort
leur scénario s'effondre quand
l'autopsié révèle qu andré le floch est
mort par strangulation et qu'il a été
attaché après sa mort ce que les deux
accusés ont toujours nié pour le fils
andré le floch cette condamnation est
une satisfaction
la juste peine ceux-ci faire pour la
justice portugaise le mobile ne fait pas
de doute
les deux français ont assassiné le
skipper pour lui voler son trimaran
leur avocat a déclaré qu'il ferait
probablement appel de la décision
justice toujours en france cette foi et
cette information romain dupuy ne sera
pas jugé pour les meurtres
particulièrement violent de deux
infirmières à pau il ya tout juste trois
ans le jeune homme qui souffre de
schizophrénie a bénéficié aujourd'hui à
nouveau d'un non lieu pour raisons
psychiatriques
une décision difficile à accepter pour
les familles de victimes david bazié et
philippe dumas y un non lieu confirmé
romain dupuy toujours considéré comme
irresponsable de ses actes
la nuit où il a assassiné deux
infirmières à l'hôpital psychiatrique de
pau mariam ou les douces la soeur d'une
des victimes vient d'apprendre la
décision des magistrats de la cour
d'appel
maintenant il va falloir le dire aux
enfants comment leur expliquer qu'en
france on peut tuer sans être jugé sans
être puni
la cour d'assises me jugera donc pas
romain dupuy dont le devenir dépend
désormais des seuls médecins alors que
les parties civiles souhaitaient un
suivi socio judiciaire
aujourd'hui dans la fleur du puissant ne
sera pas malheureusement le cas alors
que si la cour d'assises avait statué
elle aurait pu prendre des dispositions
dans ce sens mais pour la première fois
la justice a ordonné une audience
publique pour décider d'un non-lieu
thérapeutique
signe que la sphère du puy a ouvert le
débat effectivement les gens pris
conscience de la difficulté et on s'est
interrogé au plus haut niveau et la loi
devrait évoluer assez favorablement vert
au moins une prise en charge différente
de ce genre de délinquants la mère de
romain dupuy était absente aujourd'hui
mais garde en elle une question pourquoi
malgré ses demandes son fils n'at-il pas
été hospitalisé d'office
bien avant le double meurtre de pau la
crise électorale et financière que
traverse le front national va t'elle
conduire le parti de jean marie le pen à
mettre en vente le paquebot le paquebot
sous le nom du siège historique du front
national depuis 1994 il est situé en
banlieue parisienne à saint cloud la
vente est en tant qu en tout cas
envisagé la raison est assez simple
le parti a besoin d'argent c'est en fait
le prix de ces derniers revers
électoraux et la nuque
pascal caron
ça tangue au front national et les sos
envoyé par le capitaine n'y ont rien
fait pas plus la souscription nationale
lancée avant l'été que le licenciement
de 25 permanents sur une cinquantaine
n'ont changé la donne
il va falloir quitter le navire vendre
ou louer le fameux paquebot le siège du
front national depuis 13 ans jean marie
le pen le laissait déjà entendre le mois
dernier nous avons une échéance qui est
à fin mars
par conséquent j'aurais dû prendre à ce
moment là une résolution soit en faveur
d'un emprunt soit en faveur de solutions
qui impliquerait ou la location ou la
vente ou ou le partage de notre de notre
siège national 5000 mètres carrés à
saint-cloud aux portes de paris
le paquebot est estimé entre 15 et 20
millions d'euros
de quoi éponger largement la tête du
front national 8 millions d'euros
empruntés pour financer la campagne des
législatives non remboursés faute
d'avoir franchi la barre fatidique des
5% des suffrages
la décision de vendre serait donc
imminente mais au paquebot aujourd'hui
nul ne voulait confirmer l'information
non il n'y a personne qui peut recevoir
aujourd'hui jean marie le pen devrait
annoncer lui-même la vente du paquebot à
son retour de vacances aux antilles qu
on le sait depuis quelques semaines la
législation sur le travail le dimanche
sera remise à plat en concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux à partir du 19
décembre
mais le parlement a anticipé les choses
pour un type de magasins les magasins
dits d'ameublement seront désormais
autorisés à ouvrir à un amendement qui
concerne qui est sûre quel bal pour les
salariés les réponses avec il junca et
olivier robert encore quelques jours et
ce magasin ne sera plus hors la loi en
ouvrant le dimanche
ici tout le monde attendait ça ça
représente 250
bruts par mois ici pas d'eau pas de se
remettre dans la poche
la différence presque un tiers notre
clientèle qui vient le dimanche et de
plus c'est des clients qui achètent et
pour nous c'est important puisqu'on fait
presque le quart de notre activité sur
cette journée là uniquement de bonnes
affaires en perspective car cette nuit
les sénateurs ont autorisé les magasins
d'ameublement à ouvrir le dimanche sur
tout le territoire
côté salariés ce travail dominical se
fera sur la base du volontariat sera
payé double et donnera droit à un repos
compensateur
jusqu'à présent les magasins
d'ameublement étaient autorisés à ouvrir
cinq dimanches par an sinon il risquait
jusqu'à 50000 euros damende le
changement de loi cette nuit a fait
bondir les syndicats
c'est en fait complètement fait pour
faire plaisir à quelques enseignes
encore une fois quelques grandes
enseignes qui aujourd'hui sont hors la
loi condamnés et qu'ils ont à payer de
lourdes amendes
l faut savoir que en trichant elles font
mourir des dizaines de petites
entreprises et dont perd ses emplois
c'est de la concurrence déloyale de la
concurrence déloyale pour la majorité
des magasins d'ameublement qui pour la
plupart sont de petites entreprises
si nous devions changer cette
réglementation et ouvrir plus de
dimanches dans l'année
eh bien ça nous engendrerait des frais
insupportable syndicats et
professionnels du secteur regrette
l'absence de discussions le changement
de la loi devrait être entérinée jeudi
prochain à l'assemblée
c'est l'heure des premiers bilans de
l'année scolaire pour les enfants les
notes le comportement le bien-être de
l'écolier voilà des sujets d'inquiétude
pour les parents mais alors où fixer la
barre de la réussite est bien les
parents auraient tendance à mettre trop
de pression sur l'enfant c'est en tout
cas le point de vue des psychologues
conséquences des blocages chez l'enfant
ces grands formats de ce soir anne guéri
et pascal stelletta après l'école
manolis à un cours particulier pour
combler ces lacunes
il a été déstabilisé quand il a changé
d'établissement c'était il ya deux ans
j'étais bien à tous les enfants qui en
nouvelle calédonie personnes bizarres
autrement dit des notes qui flanche a
priori rien de si grave mais suffisant
pour alarmer son père il fallait
absolument résoudre ce problème très
rapidement on peut pas en six ans va
voir comment va évoluer dans le bon dans
le mauvais sens
cours particuliers d'un côté
consultations si de l'autre et manolis
n'est pas le seul le cabinet ne
désemplit pas les enfants se succèdent
avec au coeur de leurs angoisses l'école
quand les enfants pour manolis il s'agit
de reprendre confiance
son papa vient de me dire que t'étais
drôlement plus concentré sur dix est
qu'avec la méthode
j'étais un peu enfermé
on a envie que son enfant soit bien cool
dans ses baskets heureux et puis
s'épanouir dans sa vie dans sa vie
d'enfant pour pour avoir après une vie
une vie je l'espère merveilleuse m'a dit
avait des soucis que tu étais inquiète
d'aller à l'école c'est ça c'est ça que
tu t'en ceci turmel au vent pour mélanie
il faut atténuer cette peur au ventre
qui la paralyse qu'est ce que tu fais
comme tu veux qu'à l'école mais pourquoi
tu n'y vas pas trop peur c'est
angoissant pendant sa fille avec un
chrono passe entre 1 41 % des 5 10 ans
qui consultent le font pour des
problèmes scolaires
ce n'est pas une mode dit le psychologue
juste le signe que les enfants
d'aujourd'hui portent une lourde charge
l'obligation de réussir ce qu'on voit
c'est effectivement une plus grande
tolérance
balanod réussite scolaire son enfant on
supporte pas qu'il ait de mauvaises
notes on supporte pas qu'il puisse
redoublé on s'inquiète beaucoup sur son
devenir cette espèce de projection
négative et dramatiques sur messi
réussit pas maintenant à 6 en 8 ans ou
dix ans qu'est ce qui va faire plus tard
je suis même trop tu m'aides toufflin
cité des enfants est telle qu'on en
débat régulièrement sur les ondes de
cette nouvelle radio destinée à la fin
de ma maman est toujours là elle est
très présent je voulais absolument qu'il
faut équilibrer les miens étaient à
l'écouté et un constat derrière le
stress des enfants se profile le mal
être des parents inquiets tendue dans
leur quête du bonheur familial dans leur
désir aussi d'enfants parfait on leur en
demande beaucoup et on les aime
tellement et on veut tellement qu'il
nous rassure et on projet tellement
notre idéal sur eux que de fait il se
retrouve plus ou moins dans des
situations à risque
les parents qui eux mêmes vive un peu le
le monde environnant comme étant
hostiles difficile le monde du travail
l'écologie etc reporte sur la sphère
familiale et sur l'enfant tous leurs
idéaux et voilà ils veulent ils veulent
des enfants qui qui les épanouissent en
étant eux-mêmes épanouie dans ce paysage
familial que l'on voudrait idéal le
moindre trouble chez l'enfant est
traquée et c'est cette insatisfaction
qui encombrent souvent les cabinets des
psychologues de l'enfant mais voilà une
initiative qui devrait en tout cas
rassuré les parents à quelques jours des
vacances de noël si vous partez skier
plusieurs centaines de collégiens des
hautes-alpes ont été sensibilisés aux
dangers de la montagne
reportage près de gap yannick à rossi et
hattrick l'an terminaux s'il ya de la
lecture au programme aujourd'hui c'est
celle du paysage ou pas c'est pour
éviter les pièges en montagne pour ne
pas se retrouver sous une avalanche
des fois on est obligé de renoncer
vis-à-vis des conditions nivologiques il
est vraiment se veulent ils aidé à sous
donc comme on a de temps pourra chercher
quelqu'un
réunis là et en cas de pépin il faudra
réagir très vite perçu passa rouge tu as
quel maître il faut diminuer 8 mètres
appareil de recherche de victimes
d'avalanche pelle et sonde devront
d'être dans le sac à dos pour chaque
sortie hors piste
on nous sensibilise pour comme ça on
peut retrouver des personnes qui sont
ensevelis après des avalanches sauver
des vies encadrés par des moniteurs ou
des guides de haute montagne les
ateliers sont dans l'ensemble ludique
cette année l'accent est mis sur la
survie en milieu hostile le dard vous
aurez 0 plusieurs intervalles et là là
vous survivrez alors que dehors vous
allez mourir de froid ça n'aurait pas ça
on sert pas du tout comment est ce qu'on
sait en frais d'ahmed qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire des sportifs de haut niveau
comme nicolas bonnet champion du monde
de ski alpinisme viennent partager leur
expérience
si vous devez passer nuit sur place et
que vous avez vraiment froid aux pieds
vous pouvez mettre les pieds dans un sac
à dos par exemple
l'opération s'adresse aux 1700 élèves de
quatrième du département des montagnards
pas forcément connaisseur on essaye de
leur dire aussi c'est à mieux vous
pouvez y aller mais à un principe de
précaution
c'est d'être informé de savoir quels
dangers potentiels des dangers et des
victimes chaque hiver déjà deux morts au
début du mois dans les alpes de haute
provence lors d'une randonnée à
raquettes le sport avec la belle
performance de laure manaudou
aujourd'hui aux champins de robbie
natation en petit bassin qui se déroule
en hongrie
la française sans me retrouver son
rythme médaille d'or et record d'europe
du 100 m dos battu manuel tissier
facétieuse sur le podium implacable dans
le bassin la natation selon laure
manaudou pourrait se résumer à un
théorème plonger son corps dans l'eau il
en ressortira de l'or est parfois comme
aujourd'hui un record d'europe pour la
troisième fois d'affilée manaudou a
décroché le titre continental sur 100 m
dos 57 secondes 34 centièmes avec son
bonnet blanc à la ligne d'eau numéro
quatre au centre de l'écran
la française a confirmé les progrès
effectués depuis qu'elle s'entraîne avec
son frère nicolas
les spécialistes vizquel a amélioré sa
coulée soit à 21 ans voici son treizième
titre européen le retour auprès de sa
famille n'a visiblement pas émoussé sa
rage de vaincre et ce n'était que sa
première finale en hongrie elle en
disputera trois autres demain et
dimanche
son sourire devrait donc encore éclairé
le week-end de la danse maintenant et
l'opéra garnier à paris vous propose un
très beau ballet pour les fêtes de fin
d'année qui s'intitule paquita sur la
scène la nouvelle étoile dorothée
gilbert rencontre avec sophie jouve et
d'idées d'art la voilà notre nouvelle
étoile fraîchement nommé il ya trois
semaines et qui va affronter le rôle de
paquita cher à toutes les grandes et
pour ce ballet qui multiplie les
morceaux de bravoure c'est le mariage de
la jeunesse et de l'expérience
son partenaire manuel legris a presque
le double de son âge
c'est exceptionnel de pouvoir travailler
avec quelqu'un comme la nuit puis donne
des conseils éclairés
bah moi je vais leur envoyer de
compliment parce que c'est un vrai
bonheur danse avec dorothée parce
qu'elle a une vraie joie communicative
en scène et puis en même temps moi ça me
dope énormément à 43 ans manuel legris
est un des piliers du corps de ballet
mais si bien le mélange des générations
qui fait la force de l'opéra sous la
coupole
florian magnenet simple sujet dans la
hiérarchie danse avec agnès letestu
étoiles déjà chevronnés ils forment la
deuxième distribution
c'est vrai qu'à nier c'est la danseuse
étoile a été l'étoile quand je suis
rentré donc c'est un peu c'est le mythe
quoi qu'est ce qui vous surprend chez
lui chez florian que vous découvrez
comme par son calme c'est à dire qu'il y
là il a punta une comme ça à faire mais
comme ils seront pas très très bien
compte pour l'instant donc des fois je
me retrouve un petit peu a à lui dire
sans recommander attention la cour ne
lâche pas là la concentration parce
qu'il faut il faut tenir longtemps
car paquita ces deux heures d' aventure
trépidante le temps pour cette fille de
nobles enlevé par des gitans de
retrouver ses origines et d'épouser
semprun
chaque fois que je dansais avec vanessa
moment gravé dans la mémoire parce que
je sais que malheureusement il n est pas
fou crude se transmettre l'exigence
technique et artistique de génération en
génération
car à l'opéra les étoiles ne meurent
jamais
avant de nous quitter je vous rappelle
cette vague de froid qui va s'accentuer
cette nuit sur l'ensemble du territoire
les températures prévues pour cette nuit
- 3 à rennes lyon et amiens - 4 à reims
- 6 à aurillac - un en région parisienne
le plan grand froid de niveau ii a été
déclenché dans une vingtaine de
départements
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve dès demain 13h pour le journal
et pour le magazine 13h15 le samedi dans
un instant la météo isabelle martinez
suivi du point route de valérie maurice
tu à 20h50 à téléfilm inédit et du
suspense avec mort prématurée belle
soirée à vous et à demain
info en continu c'est aussi sur france 2
point fr